the next step is to establish the key
performance indicators or KPIs for your
business this is an important step for
you to monitor and understand how your
company's monetization plan is
performing in successful companies like
Udacity in Google we love data in
numbers the main reason is that with
regard to monetization numbers give a
clear picture on where you're standing
numbers will tell a real true story no
excuses or emotion here all you need to
do is listen and act if the numbers show
you are not going up into the right but
rather decline you need to take action
fast however you can only do it if you
have meaningful KPIs that you are
constantly measure we are not saying
that all month will be positive in terms
of monetization in fact for every
startups there are many weeks where you
encounter major problems well
distinguish successful entrepreneurs is
the way they deal with those issues and
problems so how can you increase your
odds of building a sustainable business
it's a fact that both luck and timing
play a role but you can improve your
odds with good planning and the agility
to maneuver when things change